america was founded in like 1480 [ __ ] i
don't know
on the principle of [ __ ] you that is
american
that is the american way we have always
taught our children great straight from
birth
[ __ ] you and just [ __ ] all y'all and go
to hell and let's see how badly we can
screw up the entire world
so anyway we landed on the shores of new
jersey
and the small native americans came out
and they were like
something nerds nice belts on your hat
and we were all
much careful you i don't think we're
going to get along oh no we're starving
and then they're like
you need some protein bruh here take
this fish in this corn thing and we're
like
oh this is awesome you guys are amazing
hey can we have all this country and the
small native americans were like i don't
know that doesn't seem very fair to us
and then they go off their business and
we're like we got to get rid of these
guys because we're suddenly turning into
giant [ __ ]
and then we decide oh we can we can we
can cooperate you you might need
something from us we might need
something from you and you're like
maybe we need more sweat towels for our
massive workouts because
native americans are so amazingly
awesome and they are
but we were like oh yeah yeah yeah sure
yeah sure
hey uh smallpox larry you got a few
spare blankets so we could toss and then
we killed them all
and we killed them all and that's how we
started our tradition of [ __ ] you
and then then we we're total dick bags
americans
founded their entire nation on killing
people and taking their stuff
and that's the history of america that's
literally all i've got for this episode
unless for some damn reason you want me
to tell more history of him
what is what am i even doing here is it
my birthday
thanks mom we need some place very dark
why do we need someplace dark what are
you doing to me